alors il ya une jeunesse vous savez la
jeunesse n'est pas seulement celle qui
est qu'ils sont sur les ronds points
mais il faut pas négliger celles qui
sont sur les grands points parce qu'ils
revendiquent ils ont aussi des
revendications qu'ils ont des
revendications sur les problèmes
d'éducation parce que vous savez
monsieur ce que demande la
guadeloupe et la martinique
c'est d'être d'avoir le même
fonctionnement que
les jeunes
français de l'hexagone ils veulent à
temps ils veulent du travail d'accord
ils veulent une bonne éducation sur le
banc ils veulent que toutes ces grosses
sociétés qui se monte en guadeloupe les
sociétés de propriétaires qui vivent en
hexagone qui sont les puissances de
l'hexagone qui se montrent en quoi le
père mathy embauchent ces jeunes parce
que vous savez depuis le bus mis
d'hommes où la guadeloupe et la
martinique a été des peuples et parce
que et la réunion aussi pour que les
ultra marins viennent travailler ici aux
ptt chez simca chez renault
et pour dans les métiers de services
médicaux médical les hôpitaux pourquoi
c'est parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
chômage dont au lieu de développer le
pays ils ont préféré enlever les
guadeloupéens et les martiniquais pour
venir travailler ici d'accord et ils ont
des peuples et la guadeloupe ils n'ont
pas voulu faire progresser ce pays
développés ce pays économiquement à
l'époque de mes parents en guadeloupe on
faisait des yaourts voilà on faisait du
contreplaqué il y avait du sucre mais il
faut qu'on a trouvé la betterave is you
n'a plus besoin du sucre de là bas une
fois qu'on a toutes utilisées et que le
chômage monte est il ils ont préféré
vider le pays que construire le pays
pour que les jeunes puissent rester nous
ils ont mis en place le bus mis d'hommes
pour que les jeunes viennent ici et ne
puisse pas repartir et aujourd'hui on a
encore ce problème de chômage avec des
contenaires d'aliments qui arrive pour
que les gens et ce
se nourrir avec des produits avec trop
de sucre et devenir obèses voilà donc
c'est devenu ils touchent le rsa il
touche le chômage et puis ensuite il
achète ce sont devenus des consommateurs
sur pied mais c'est parce qu'ils veulent
monsieur ils veulent partir faire des
études et revenir chez de travailler
c'est ça la réalité
[Musique]